triple digits showed up without a
problem this weekend 105 106
saturday and sunday a few mid-level
clouds around yesterday let's check
valley temperatures right now we have
lots of clear skies sun is up and we are
heating up
84 on the strip 87 green valley 81
mountain's edge one of the cooler spots
summerlin you just dropped 79. 84 out
there at sunrise mountain and henderson
with mid 70s red rock and 65 up at kyle
canyon and just check death valley
finally dropped below 100 degrees after
hitting 117 yesterday afternoon low 80s
for perhaps mid 80s for sandy valley
indian springs you've got some upper 70s
cali inning down to 69 52 in ely got 82
up the road in mesquite and out to
boulder city and 84 in laughlin with oh
wow 707 degrees ah in kingman it is warm
yeah well the price is right do you want
to lose the seven or do you want to lose
the zero
which one the first seven so it's just
seven
all right that's why we don't let john
do the weather 105 for today although
707 isn't so good either 105 is what
we're looking for 103 is the normal
sunrise was 5 26 and sunset at 802 and
as i mentioned before all the records
for june are in the one team so we've
only got four days of june left 77 for
mount charleston today about a 20 chance
of some afternoon thunderstorms up there
if you do have some hiking plans if you
have to be in the mountains hopefully
you can get that over with by midday
because the afternoon is where we'll
start to see the clouds popping up the
monsoon is still very active we'll look
closer at that radar here in a moment
showers and thunderstorms a string of
them all the way up through the
northeast and down to the gulf coast
where there's lots of moisture bubbling
up there but there's still flash flood
watches posted all through central new
mexico
as the monsoon is now aimed right back
into new mexico southeast arizona heat
watches and advisories posted for parts
of southern california up into oregon
and washington with temps in the mid to
upper 90s so so hot across the west
thanks to high pressure and we had some
good convection southeast of clark
county look at that oh so close last
night and all along interstate 40 south
of kingman so we will look for possible
lightning in the mountains and the
closer you are to the foothills today
you could get in on some outflow gusty
winds or maybe even some lightning or a
sprinkle 105 for the valley same
scenario for tomorrow even hotter for
the valley though 107 and then we get
some gusty winds tuesday and wednesday
afternoon even some breezy winds to
finish the week but we do start to cool
down as we head into july ever so
slightly and i use the word cool it's
relative 102 sunday 103 for the fourth
of july